welcome to simply perfect where we share
some of our favorite but on tequila
cocktails
the Jalisco mule it's almost as easy to
make as it is to drink the key to this
drink is a frosty copper cup but don't
despair if you don't have a copper cup
use a highball glass or a rocks glass
whatever you have on hand so that we add
half an ounce of fresh squeezed lime
juice it's about the juice of half a
lime and two ounces of patron reposado
tequila and then we top it off with
about three ounces of ginger brew
give the drink a stir this drink is such
a simple platform that it opens itself
to all kinds of interpretation it's
really easy to put your own twist on
this muddle some fresh herbs or berries
give it a dash of bitters
lastly top the cup off with more crushed
ice and I like to garnish it with a lime
wheel and a little piece of candied
ginger and there you have it
the jalisco Mule Cheers
you